bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors aux
communicants que je m'adresse comment
est-ce que vous jugez vous la gestion de
cette crise justement sur le plan de la
communication
il est clair que de toute façon on a
pris du retard dès le début à partir du
moment où le ministre la ministre de la
santé au mois de janvier
de cette année déclaré que finalement le
virus devrait être probablement
contenues à la chine on a voulu émettre
un message qui était particulièrement
rassurant mais qui n'a vraisemblablement
pas permis une estimation réelle de la
menace donc à partir de cet élan on voit
qu'aujourd'hui l'exécutif en france le
cours en permanence après les événements
et on peut considérer que la
communication dans la dernière séquence
c'est à dire depuis l'intervention du
président de la république jeudi et
l'annoncent entre autres à la fois du
maintien des municipales mais aussi
d'autre part de la fermeture des écoles
a donné lieu à une communication s'est
cassé depuis jeudi c'est à dire que avec
deux autres séquences de communication
on a laissé où on a délégué au premier
ministre d annonce encore plus
coercitives qui sont tombés parfois un
peu brutalement comme cette annonce
d'hier où le premier ministre a annoncé
la fermeture à la fois des bars des
restaurants et de la plupart des
commerces sens disons préparation de
l'opinion et notamment des acteurs
économiques à cette décision prochaine
annonce en tout cas ce que vous vous
préparez par exemple à une annonce qui
va encore plus loin c'est à dire un
confinement généralisée
par écouter on verra exactement ce qui
va se passer mais en face est une des
hypothèses sur laquelle
vraisemblablement au vu des chiffres et
des informations que possèdent
aujourd'hui les autorités sanitaires et
les pouvoirs publics
on peut éventuellement s'attendre à des
mesures de confinement sur un temps
donné vraisemblablement d'ailleurs assez
long mais pour l'instant ça reste encore
une hypothèse à ce stade vous parliez de
restriction un jeu j'ai un petit peu
tardive beaucoup de pays ferment leurs
frontières c'est le cas de l'allemagne
on a appris aujourd'hui en allemagne qui
a décidé de fermer ses frontières à
trois pays dont la france l'autriche 1
va interdire les rassemblements de plus
de cinq personnes
rien du côté français même si on prévoit
c'est vrai renforcement des contrôles
aux frontières
est-ce que c'est selon vous une mesure
juste de ne pas prendre ce type de
mesure à écouter en effet là aussi ça
fait partie si vous voulez des des
aspérités de la communication du
gouvernement qui d'un côté prend des
communes et des mesures qui sont en
effet les mesures absolument
indispensable à ces faire comme encore
une fois la fermeture des commerces où
nous la fermeture des écoles mais qui
laisse d'autres pans totalement ouvert
je pense notamment par exemple aux
transports en commun qui continuent à
circuler même si on a lancé déjà un
certain nombre de restrictions et cette
question des frontières est une question
essentielle qui est ray apparaît bien
évidemment à l'occasion de cette crise
sanitaire et quand on voit un certain
nombre de nos voisins notamment les
allemands les italiens qui prennent des
mesures de contrôle aujourd'hui très
strictes aux frontières et voire de
fermeture
on peut s'interroger sur le dit
on la dynamique en matière de gestion du
risque qui est celle de l'exécutif
parce que même si la fermeture des
frontières on ne résout pas
fondamentalement la question de la
propagation du virus
on peut peut-être considéré qu' elle
permet tout au moins de limiter en tout
cas de contrôler un peu mieux fait qu on
entre à peine au niveau du stade iii de
l'épidémie faut quand même attendre
plusieurs semaines pour faire le bilan
final
mais selon vous cette crise est-ce
qu'elle aura de toute façon des
répercussions sur le quinquennat des
mariannes marron ah oui totalement je
pense que c'est le deuxième grand moment
après la crise des gilet jaune du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron parce que
c'est une crise qui l'obligent en
profondeur à dison réévalué revoir son
logiciel politique
emmanuel macron finalement c'était le
candidat de la mondialisation optimistes
de la mondialisation heureuse et cette
crise sanitaire finalement pose la
question fondamentale quand même malgré
tout de la maîtrise de la souveraineté
du retour de l'état de la nécessité de
mettre un certain nombre de biens comme
il l'a rappelé d'ailleurs lui-même lors
de son intervention jeudi soir de mettre
un certain nombre de bien haut
disons de au delà du marché donc on sent
bien qu'il y à là aujourd'hui une
pression des événements très fortes qui
pèsent sur la gouvernance et la suite de
ce quinquennat
merci beaucoup à vous arnaud un
benedetti je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste de la communication
politique merci d'avoir réagi en direct
sur rt france